thank you mr speaker may i congratulate  my right honourable friend and welcome  her to her position as the third  united kingdom  can i ask my right honourable friend why  does she think it is that all three  female prime ministers have been  conservative  [Applause]  well i i thank my right honourable  friend for her fantastic question i look  forward to calling on her advice  uh from her time in office as i start as  i start my work as i start my work as  prime minister it is it is quite  extraordinary isn't it but there doesn't  seem to be  uh the ability in the labour party to  find  a  a female leader indeed a leader who  doesn't come from north london  [Applause]